oh I know where you're hiding give me
the third clap I'm gonna get to know
I can hear you breathing haha you took
your blindfold off I went
you weren't even warm um I was in
Christine and Nancy's room Zelda's made
entirely your own imagination no see
were there all along the idea you see
of course if anything is not your liking
I'll change it it's perfect
from your perfect irresistible
imagination okay I look like I've been
attacked that's not my fault well I know
it's my fault to me even out the bottom
okay would you just stop carving stop
move I'm making shorts everybody likes
shorts Jesus hold still please just what
that feels awkward weird just don't
touch that area well don't duck down
you're gonna suck my hand up there we
won't stop pulling my pants off Jesus
what what are those
what don't stop it so my Spanx they hold
everything together help dr. fassbach
find whatever it is he needs rod I want
it for the circumstances speak for
itself
can't help you can't leave my family
take a look around here mr. Wayne
each and every one of these people are
here because they serve a purpose
there's no room here for non-essential
personnel you want to help your family
let's figure out how we stop this why
did you allow me to move we all make
mistakes
hmm I surrendered to you because despite
your attempt to convince me otherwise
you've seemed to have a conscience
mr. CAC if you did not then it would be
impossible for me to convince you of the
truth two three one seven four six one
one coordinates not far from Earth if
you want to know why I did what I did
don't take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Johnny Worthington president of roar
Omega roar what's your name big blue
Jimmy Sullivan friends call me Sulley
this guy's on Sullivan with the famous
Sullivan I can't believe it that is
crazy
yeah Tom de I'm sorry Sully any freshman
with the guts to pull off a stunt like
that has got future scarer written all
over him hey did you see me ride the pig
that took guts slow down squirt this
party it's what scare students only
oh sorry killer but you might want to
hang out with someone a little more your
speed goodbye my son
hopes and dreams troubled you you'll be
an outcast I'll kill him how he'll be a
god to them
[Music]
[Music]
Hey earth today you can leave now
see ya I'm gonna swing by are you just
gonna grab you got it
Electrify your arm you won't be able to
open your hand do this in
easy see let more go
[Music]
[Music]